so smart contracts are rather poorly
named in the think they're more properly
thought of these applications a series
of if-then-else type claudius for
drafting up and executing negotiations
the last video I did with your on
blockchain technology with a leaning
towards Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
without rehashing too much of that video
a blockchain is a technology a
distributed ledger and means of
validating and seeing series of
transactions such that no party in the
network needs to directly trust or know
anybody else and the first application
of this was cryptocurrencies most
notably Bitcoin but now people started
talking about using this blockchain
technology not just by storing sort of
transactions of bitcoins or
cryptocurrency but as storing smart
contract and wearing smart contracts
just because we using an application
that allows me to pay a taxi driver
surely I'm still going to need the taxi
lips right sharing the application to
get me in touch with whoever's offering
the service that gets a little bit
further down the rabbit hole and
introduces something called distributed
applications where in fact anyone could
you would have your smart contract that
is your business logic for negotiating
the transfer of funds to taking vbe
bouquet to the driver and the client and
then you have your front-end you can
think of it like this in a web developer
if you'll store front end HTML page to
your back-end service but instead of
having that front-end to be a web page
it could be a web page but equally it
could be a desktop application the
shortage of LimeWire and Napster
something running locally on your
machine and anyone is free to create
their own front-end to a given smart
contract application and distribute it
in any ways they like so it doesn't have
to be running from one particular
website or run by one organization it
could even be put on something called
the interplanetary file system which is
a peer-to-peer network bit of
peer-to-peer network file system such
that it can actually be taken down or
moderated by any one individual
in the way a standard website can it has
the potential at least to completely
remove the middleman the escrow account
because your smart contract ends up
performing that function an escrow is
like a third sort of impartial mediating
party is the function of uber over take
your money
uber importantly takes their cut and
then pays the driver if you have smart
contract taking the place over there's
no middleman taking the cut it really is
a technology that the represent
revolution rather than evolution and
it's something where you're going to
move away from ownership of data or
ownership of a service to designing the
best interface to that service good
service can be put up on the blockchain
technology used by anyone viewed by
anyone so the best written service that
performs the job is the one that's going
to be used most and what determining
whether an uber type outfit make money
or not is whether you've got the most
user-friendly prettiest app to interface
with the smart contracts and you could
charge a you know some for using your
particular interface to the smart
contract but we really are sort of
talking WordPress type you know with our
business logic is gone we're talking
about a sort of a user interface a nice
pretty way of interfacing with it so
there is absolutely nothing to stop an
open-source community or an individual
in their garage producing the nicest
pretty aggressive or do student
producing the nicest uber app and
distribute it for free because you hate
the time booking you can sit with either
for now is it saying that the drivers
would have to say well I won with this
kind of contact or they lock themselves
into three different types of contract
and then you just find them through our
vilified that's that's the other thing
there for you to use different contracts
different models so you could have a
smart contract that models a taxi light
service for weekdays and a different
one for for weekend's that offers young
benefit to the driver for we can and
they can absolutely make use of both
contracts in fact you can have the same
interface to both contracts so in terms
of the client finding them it's seamless
and they don't have to know or care
about but in terms of the driver they're
optimizing potentially the way they're
getting paid depending on which contract
they're using your smart contracts
because model a luggage allowance or
something like this here you end up
getting a minivan if you're taking a
whole bunch of people and a bunch of
luggage was there before blockchain that
the different contacts all set there
their danger or would it be a blockchain
for each of the contract rather that
work so that's an interesting question
there are different blockchain outfits
out there at the moment each with their
own sort of instantiation or ability to
express smart contracts so in fact
bitcoin has been expanded to allow some
kind smart contract capabilities but
it's not what it's design for the
platform that's really sort of making
headway in a big name in this area of
smart contract is simply called
aetherium and aetherium is a blockchain
that is designed not primarily to store
cryptocurrency and you know tokens and
transactions but actually to store a
global computer state and here ease of
computational operations therein could
be thought of your Braille arge very
slow global computer stored on the
blockchain how does the money work
although I said the ethereum blockchain
was not primarily a crypto currency
which it isn't you still do pay for
things in it in crypto currency to your
etherion blockchain stores a global
computer state a series of computation
operations but you paid for performing
those operations and you pay in the
arian currency which not Bitcoin but
ether and in fact they do translation
between the the ether which is the
cryptocurrency and the computational
operations which are charged in gas and
made a gas to the exchange rate the huge
example of a distributed application
that exists for the theory of network
and essentially I've got this
application here mist which I downloaded
as my front-end my GUI by means of
interfacing with the etherium Network
and the browser that allows me to keep
other distributed applications that are
out there and potentially view them as
well so distributed application I've
searched for here is a service for
converting from one cryptocurrency to
another called shape-shift and this
application I can search for it through
this browser I can put it down I can
display it this mist application the
interface is running locally on my
machine but it's negotiating when it's
sending its transactions when I'm
converting ether to Bitcoin or
vice-versa rock-forming that the
functions of a given application that I
load it's been carrying in my gateway to
the smart contracts but are hosted on
the ethereal Network and then whatever
whatever function I call which I call it
function by killing a transaction is
executed on all the nodes in the network
in parallel you've got which you watch
very slow you've got a redundant here
this your computation whatever it might
be you can you add two numbers together
it's being performed by every single
node and then agreed upon and then the
result of that is added and the global
state of the etherium virtual machine
global computer is updated together and
that you put in
andum Gehrke's for that non-value until
this hash value that labels this blog
goes ganges collection function but the
idea is that the bits of ABCDE
are being combined together they're
being shuffled they're being promoted
around to make it look more and more